it features
kylie jenner with this headline
america's women
billionaires with a b kylie
this is kylie jenner she's a tv
personality model social media icon and
business woman in november of 2015 she
launched her cosmetics business three
years later she was enlisted in forbes
as the world's youngest billionaire
she's also one of the most followed
personalities on social media with
hundreds of millions of instagram
followers and a massive following on
twitter
in 2015 she was named one of time
magazine's most influential teens
kylie first earned her riches through
various modeling projects her massive
following on social media helped her
build an insanely lucrative income
stream on instagram where she gets paid
around 1.2 million dollars for a single
post
but for her those are just rookie
numbers the vast majority of her fortune
came from her business kylie cosmetics
from tv personality to the world's
youngest billionaire this is how kylie
jenner turned her biggest insecurity
into a billion dollar cosmetic empire
she was born on august 10 1997 into a
rich and famous family her mother's side
being the famous kardashian family and
her father being a former olympian kylie
was only nine years old when she first
appeared on keeping up with the
kardashians
it ran for 20 seasons which made it one
of the longest running and most popular
reality tv series
her screen time in the series increased
as she grew up and so did her following
as she entered her late teens she
started receiving massive sponsorship
and licensing deals her mother took this
opportunity and began securing contracts
for her later on she started launching
different apparel lines at pacsun steve
madden and topshop
she also went on to launch a solo hair
extensions line with bellamy hair
her career as a model also became hugely
successful she started to make an insane
amount of money from endorsements as
well when she was 16 years old she
delved into the beauty industry creating
two types of nail polish for nicole by
opi
she received 100 000 for her endorsement
of the brand she then ventured into
jewelry design along with her sister
kendall they also invested in shoes
handbags and hair extensions
by then kylie had built up a massive fan
base and a very engaged audience
she gained a lot of experience in
business and had great success selling
products for other people and various
brands so she decided to create her own
products to sell she was always insecure
about her lips being too small and thin
that was where the idea of kylie's lip
kit came from she turned her biggest
insecurity into a business opportunity
in 2014 at the age of 18 kylie partnered
with seed beauty a company that was
newly founded by laura thomas
the company was specifically built to
develop and manufacture global beauty
brands with a focus on speed and
efficiency of product development
this allowed them to beat other
companies to market
kylie teamed up with the company and
started developing and manufacturing her
lip kit
her lip kit included a lipstick and a
matching lip liner initially a limited
batch of only 15 000 kits were made
after teasing and hyping up her lip kit
through social media in november of 2015
kylie launched her product online and
put the lip kits up for sale at a very
affordable price of 29 per kit
being the face of her brand she was able
to leverage her social media following
which essentially gave her free
advertising saving her millions in
advertising costs
with manufacturing outsourced to seed
beauty as well as utilizing the online
e-commerce platform shopify
she was able to improve the logistics of
her business and reach more customers to
generate more sales she only needed to
hire seven full-time employees
much of jenna's work on kylie cosmetics
took place on social media
she frequently promoted the brand on her
personal instagram account being the ceo
of kylie cosmetics she worked on the
marketing design and styling of her
products while her finances were handled
by her mother who also acted as her
manager
thanks to her millions of followers and
a limited supply of kits her lip kits
literally sold out in minutes and the
heavy online traffic even crashed the
website her launch was hugely successful
the fame and success of the company
continued to grow from there she even
branched out and sold a variety of
products such as eyeshadow eyeliner kits
and different types of lipsticks
through clever outsourcing and acquiring
good talent her business became a
well-oiled money-making machine
the company claimed to have sold more
than 630 million dollars worth of makeup
in its first two years and an estimated
330 million dollars in 2017.
in 2018 kylie cosmetics made a exclusive
distribution deal with ulta a beauty
retailer and claimed that her company
was on track to bring in more than 300
million dollars in revenue in november
of the following year a majority stake
in kylie cosmetics was sold to koti for
600 million dollars that gave kylie
jenner's company a 1.2 billion dollar
valuation
making her the youngest billionaire by
forbes in that same year
the moment forbes announced kylie jenner
as a self-made billionaire it was
greatly criticized many believe that she
wasn't self-made and already had enough
family money when she started her
company only two years after forbes
controversially named her the world's
youngest self-made billionaire kylie
jenner was officially left out of the
annual billionaires list
forbes reported in 2020 kylie jenner
along with her mother and manager chris
jenner had overstated their wealth in
documents that were sent to the magazine
there's speculation that kylie's
business began as a way to cash in on a
minor scandal
she spent more than a year denying
tabloid speculation that she was using
lip filler injections before eventually
confessing in may 2015.
far from being embarrassed about being
caught in a lie she and her mother chris
seized it as a marketing opportunity and
started kylie cosmetics
critics say her billion may be a big lie
the self-made billionaire kylie jenner
allegedly inflated the size of her
cosmetics business for years forbes
reported that kylie's business was
significantly smaller and less
profitable than previously thought
the report cited public files released
by beauty giant coty which bought half
of jenna's company as evidence that the
22 year old entrepreneur had
consistently lied about her fortune
forbes also claimed that her family went
as far as creating tax returns that were
lightly forged in a desperate attempt to
look richer than they already were
moreover they claimed that the business
was never that big to begin with and
that jenners have lied about it every
year since 2016
including having their accountant draft
tax returns with false numbers to help
juice estimates of kylie's earnings and
net worth
forbes claimed that while they can't
prove that those documents were fake
they reported it's clear that kylie's
cap has been lying
there's also the issue of profit forbes
had been estimating that her business
which has little overhead was netting 44
net margins
but coty's filings indicate that kylie's
profits are likely lower at only around
25 net margins
the financial magazine garnered
widespread criticism in march 2019 when
it declared jenna the world's youngest
self-made billionaire a controversial
label given the weight of her last name
and the massive platform it provides she
defended herself on twitter stating that
she never asked for any title or tried
to lie her way there ever but experts
who spoke with the magazine believe
jenna's company was never as big as she
claimed it was
most recently her net worth has been
estimated to be around 700 million
dollars
even though she lost her spot in forbes
list of billionaires she still has a
massive following on social media and
her business is still profitable
kylie now lives with her boyfriend
travis scott in their mansion in houston
kylie also recently launched her
swimwear collection which turned out to
be a disaster many buyers were claiming
that the material was see-through and
was not for a realistically natural body
however she is in the process of turning
it around but in the meantime she is
focusing on her health and well-being
with the upcoming birth of her child
[Music]
there's a lesson in every journey what
can we learn from kylie jenner's rise to
the top
well
she took her biggest insecurity and
turned it into a billion dollar business
a big part of entrepreneurship is the
ability to solve problems she recognized
that a lot of her fans had the problem
of being insecure about their lips
spotting an opportunity in the market
she came up with a product that solved
the problem of having small and thin
lips by leveraging her social media and
through clever outsourcing her biggest
insecurity eventually made her a fortune
there's no doubt she's had massive
success with her businesses she's
incredibly successful and still has a
massive following on social media
but many argue that she was never really
self-made as she was born into wealth
and fame compared to other self-made
entrepreneurs who genuinely started out
with nothing and had to work their way
up
but that shouldn't take away anything
from her success
she worked hard by consistently
interacting with her fan base and built
her business from the ground up by using
a multi-platform approach on social
media creating content for instagram
twitter snapchat and youtube
she was able to expand her audience and
leveraged her fame and turned her
biggest insecurity into a hugely
successful business what do you think
was she really self-made or did she just
take advantage of her family's fame and
fortune the comment section in this one
will be very interesting
thanks for staying till the end of this
video if you enjoyed this video then be
sure to hit the like button drop a
comment subscribe and hit the
notification bell for more content like
this
also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you in the
next one